I haven't depicts her I fixed your pet
Carol and Raj have a problem
his name is dr. Greenwald right after
Raj moved in with me my cat dr.
Greenwald has behaved like a demon from
hell even in Texas where we're sleeping
I gave Carolyn ultimatum either dr.
Greenwald goes or I do I could hop for
the pet fixer for geophone hat spends
his nights entering online sweepstakes
and screaming into a pillow but by day
he's an expert in pet behavior elitism
Giorgio requests that Raj and Carol stay
in a budget hotel for two weeks while he
fixes dr. Greenwald
[Music]
[Applause]
you're still here I have good news mr.
greenbeans
is fixed I am the pizza kitty cat come
here you know I leave here now okay wait
I show you I show you watch
[Music]
discusting
if you have any information on these two
frogs please call our anonymous tipline
have 1-800 gotcha and coming up on the
program I'll ask the question see
anything you like
shortly after this video was captured
serial creep
Robert foot disappeared if you want to
help bring dangerous sexual deviants
like this to justice call my tip line at
1 this looks like a job for the pet
fixer
[Applause]
[Music]
it's great it's not only one show I
think it's seven different shows you're
welcome TBS hey thanks for watching be
sure to click subscribe to see even more
great Conan clips you may now return to
your pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography